were Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski says powerful steps are being
made to root out corruption at the
highest levels of government this as he
appeals for more military and financial
aid from the International Community or
within the past hour Ukraine's Deputy
defense minister via
polloff has resigned following an
allegation that his Department overpaid
suppliers for food for soldiers
anti-corruption police on Sunday said
they have also detained the deputy
infrastructure Minister on suspicion of
receiving Kickbacks of up to four
hundred thousand dollars during the
importing of generators while zolinski
said corrupt officials are to be rounded
up and jailed as part of a zero
tolerance policy well let's go to
Natasha Butler who's in key for us and
can you tell us more about the growing
concern around corruption there
well the Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski did indicate on Monday in his
nightly address that he would be making
some changes in his ministries following
a number of corruption uh scandals now
as you outlined there a number of top
officials including the deputy
infrastructure Minister the deputy
defense minister have either been sacked
or resigned also prosecutor General the
deputy head of the presidential office
so a number of people who are having to
step down or have resigned because of
links to some of these corruption
scandals now what Vladimir zielinski is
obviously trying to do is show Western
powers that are pouring in Aid and
military aid and financial help to
Ukraine that Kiev is taking this sort of
thing very seriously indeed and that
that Aid and money is being used for the
right reasons and not being siphoned off
by some government officials of course
cleaning up corruption is one of the
conditions also for Ukraine to do if it
wants to be part of the European Union
and we know that steps are already
underway for Ukraine to accede to the
block and this all is happening at the
same time that the NATO Secretary
General is meeting Germany's defense
minister on potentially sending tanks to
Ukraine has there been any update on
that
well quite frankly nothing new we're in
the same position that we've been in for
the past days in the past weeks you have
uh the German defense minister standing
alongside the head of NATO saying that
Germany still hasn't taken a decision on
whether it is going to send its leopard
tanks or whether it's going to allow
others to send its tanks what the German
defense minister said is that NATO must
not be party to the war in Ukraine a lot
of concern in Berlin that sending these
tanks offensive weapons could send the
wrong signal to Moscow could escalate
the conflict he also said that look any
decision that is going to be taken will
be taken by the German Chancellor Olaf
Schultz they will be taken at that level
and he said look perhaps Olaf Schultz
needs time he needs a few days to make
these decisions well for the ukrainians
there is no time they say every single
day that these decisions are not being
made is another day that lives are being
lost here in Ukraine okay thank you so
much for that update that's Natasha
Butler for us and key